Петро Порошенко пане президенте
президент Байден пов'язав війну Ізраїля
проти хамасу з війною України проти
Росії на його думку це однакові речі чи
бачите ви зв'язок між протистоянням
Ізраїлю і хамасу з протистоянням України
і
Росії дуже дякую ніку Найперше я хочу
подякувати пітеру та усім учасникам
галіфак міжнародного безпекового
форуму усі мої друзі єдині і солідарні з
Україною і цього року всі теми
починаються зі слова
Україна Чому так сталося тому що зараз
вирішальний момент у
війні
цієї ночі Мені зателефонували і
повідомили що брат мого головного
дипломатичного радника сьогодні в гуляй
полі цієї ночі там розпочалася тактична
наступальна операція Мені зателефонували
з Авдіївки коли почалась війна там було
27 000
[музика]
людей
сьогодні в авдіївці 500
людей чи знаєте ви скільки російських
терористів та окупантів були знищені під
авдіївкою за останні 24
години
451 усе це завдяки збройним силам
України які роблять все можливе щоб
захистити
світ
кожного
дня Водночас Україна щодня платить ціну
через
зволікання зволікання з постачанням
озброєння зволікання з постачанням
високотехнологічного озброєння
зволікання із санкціями сотні цивільних
сотні військових ось
ціна
та Разом з тим Я хочу донести меседж що
Україна бореться не через те що Путін
прийшов за Донбасом не за запоріжжям
херсоном і навіть не за Києвом звідки я
це знаю від
Путіна на початку війни президент Байден
прем'єр-міністр Великої Британії канцлер
Німеччини і президент Франції провели
переговори із
Путіним
вони намагалися переконати його не
починати
війну ви пам'ятаєте що відповів Путін
відповідей було
декілька перше ми не почнемо війну я
гарантую І що ж це означає будь ласка не
довіряйте Путіну жодному його
слову він Агент кдб Він ніколи не
говорить правду
друге давайте вести перемовини з Путіним
Путін сказав добре але ось вам мій
Ультиматум перше НАТО повинно
повернутись назад до кордонів
року Україна повинна бути зоною впливу
Росії разом зі всіма пострадянськими
країнами Ось чому Путін розв'язав цю в
Ось чому Путін розв'язав цю
війну не через демілітаризацію Чи
денацифікацію
це війна проти всього вільного
світу але Україна бореться за весь
вільний світ Україна - це
демократія і коли ви питаєте який
зв'язок з Ізраїлем Ізраїль - це також
демократія це боротьба Росії проти
Української демократії Тому що Путін
почав війну у
2014 через те що Україна хотіла стати
членом НАТО і Європейського Союзу і ми
почали впроваджувати
реформи джерелом війни причиною війни в
Україні і також
Ізраїлі
є Путін Росія і російська вісь
зла
Іран Північна Корея Тож у нас один ворог
Але є одна відмінність війна в Україні є
в 50 разів більшою ніж в Ізраїлі в 50
разів більшою територіальнону полем бою
військовою
міццю
і я абсолютно переконаний Коли Україна
переможе це буде перемога не лише для
України але й Для Білорусі Вітаю моїх
білоруських
друзів це буде перемога для
Молдови це буде перемога для
Грузії це буде перемога для
Ізраїлю саме тому президент Байден
абсолютно має рацію що у нас один ворог
І що нам потрібно для цієї Перемоги
зброя санкції та єдність єдність між
Україною та
Ізраїлем тому що іноді коли я спілкуюсь
з прем'єр-міністром Ізраїлю Він
каже Так ми розуміємо ми разом з вами
але ми не можемо у нас немає права
дратувати
Путіна
я відповідаю будь ласка повірте мені
деякі очільники України також ненавиділи
ідею дратувати Путіна але незалежно від
вас незалежно від нас Путін нападе
використовуючи
терористів і ніхто не знає коли це
станеться завтра Путін може напасти на
Балкани завтра Путін може напасти на
Близький Схід саме тому ми повинні
зберігати
єдністьт
ми бачимо як Росія у соцмережах у ЗМІ на
дипломатичному рівні реагує на те що
відбувається у секторі
гази Росія також бачить політичну
перевагу в цьому особливо на глобальному
півдні ви бачите щось ще більш пряме чи
бачите ви участь Росії чи російських
посередників напередодні вторгнення
хамасу 7
жовтня
Я абсолютно впевнений у причетності
Росії і Це військовий злочин який слід
негайно
розслідувати Я особисто знаю як
президент України який стиль бойовиків
Вагнера вони атакують нас з 2014
року вони
таку ж тактику як хамас в Ізраїлі вони
називають це м'ясний наступ незалежно
від того скільки терористів
загине Вони не дають їм жодного шансу
повернутися відкриваючи по них Вогонь і
Вагнер доручив тренувати терористів
хамас на Близькому Сході включно із
сирією ймовірно і у
газі
у цій ситуації Це ще один доказ у нас
спільний ворог
зловмисник І це ще одна причина чому ми
повинні бути
єдиними у наступному році буде уявляєте
70 виборів для понад 3х млрдів
людей будь ласка
не допустіть щоб Україна стала
заручником виборчої
кампанії Оскільки ми говоримо про
цінності Ми не говоримо про політичну
перемогу гроші чи ще щось
інше Ви повинні обрати між грошима і
цінностями і ще в українській війні
немає сірої зони лише біла і
чорна
Якщо ви хочете сидіти осторонь ви на
чорному боці Якщо ви хочете відкласти
рішення ви на чорному боці Якщо ви
хочете зупинити призупинити або
використати українську справу з
будь-якої іншої причини ви на боці
Путіна тому що це зволікання А ціна яку
ми платимо за
зволікання величезна Я дуже радий за
наших партнерів дуже задоволений збро
без вас ми платили б значно вищу
ціну але якщо ви зволікаєте на рік ми
даємо Путіну будувати лінію соровікіна
Якщо ви зволікаєте на півтора року Ви
допомагаєте Путіну розробляти систему
протиповітряної
оборони і сьогодні коли ми проводимо
наступальну операцію в авдіївці ми маємо
повне панування військо повітряних сил
Росії в повітрі тому будь ласка не
зволікайте позавчора Я був на позиціях
на сході нашої країни побачив і навіть
проїхав На американському
абраamс
Браво нам це було потрібно рік тому але
принаймні зараз це зміцнює нашу
спільноту але зверніть увагу це зовсім
інша
війна такого типу війни у світі ніколи
не було про це можна запитати у
військового це війна Дронів це війна
систем радіоелектронної боротьби а
ефективність маленьких і дешевих fpv
Дронів може бути більшою ніж велика
високоточна
артилерія тому я за власні кошти
постачаю нашим наступальним військам
2000 fpv Дронів будь ласка Зберігайте
єдність будь ласка робіть Максимум що
можете наприклад ви сказали що у нас є
дискусія щодо бюджету в США будь ласка
використовуйте заморожені як російські
активи 300 міль просимо негайно
направити на посилення української армії
тому що це найкраща інвестиція яку ви
можете собі
уявити
давайте перейдемо до запитань цієї
панелі і ми постараємося відповісти на
стільки запитань скільки зможемо а потім
перейдемо до наступної панелі Давайте
почнемо із кінця
залу Вітаю Мене звати сідхарт
вардараджан Я журналіст із ньюделі
Індія Дуже дякую за цю
і я маю відчуття що десь ми робимо
ведмежу послугу Україні та народу
України проводячи порівняння з
ізраїльсько-палестинською
війною Останнє що я перевіряв Україна не
вторглася в жодну країну Україна не
окуповує чужої території Україна не
використовує Я бачив заяву ВВП Так я маю
на увазі що газа на межі люди гази на
межі голодної смерті Це не те що робить
Україна правда тож я бачу роблячи таке
порівняння ми робимо ведмежу послугу
панель
погоджується звичайно Алісія
кернс Отже перше що я б сказала що ми
давали Україні досить послідовну
підтримку щоб вижити а не перемогти це
моральне
зречення я пам'ятаю коли рік тому ми
сиділи на мюнхенській конференції з
безпеки і Світові лідери стали і
святкували що Україна все ще вільна що
Україна все ще стоїть ніби це була наша
історія успіху ганебно що через рік ми
говорили Слава Богу що Україна ще стоїть
а не те що ми їх захистили і дали
достатньо щоб їм перемогти коли Справа
доходить до порівнянь наразі
наголошується багато моментів жозеп
борель сказав Що єс втратив багато
підтримки з боку глобального півдня
через свою позицію щодо підтримки права
Ізраїлю на захист хоча це право на
захист в рамках міжнародного
гуманітарного права питання яке я хочу
поставити коли мова йде про порівняння
полягає в тому чому існують такі
подвійні стандарти де був глобальний
південь чи країни середнього сходу коли
мова зайшла про Україну Чому коли я
їжджу по світу Люди з якими я прошу
двосторонніх відносин є не моїми
традиційними партнерами а країнами які
відмовилися говорити та підтримувати
Україну і все ж зараз вони виступають
проти Ізраїлю де в цьому кваліфікація
але ще один момент який я хотіла б
сказати про справедливість і
кваліфікацію полягає в тому чому західні
країни бігають навколо і кажуть що
зеленському потрібно більше боротися з
корупцією зеленському Потрібно провести
вибори зеленському потрібно взяти себе в
руки але закликів до нетаньяху провести
вибори немає Немає закликів до нетаньяху
піти у відставку немає закликів до
нетаньяху постати Перед судом через який
він збирається пройти Ми повинні
припинити ці подвійні стандарти давайте
визнаємо що ми незадоволені тим як ідуть
справи але глобальний південь не може
зараз кричати на підтримку палестини
коли вони мовчали щодо України і це
подвійні стандарти які ніхто не визнає